c'est une façon de lui parler d'amour
mais autrement tu lui parles d'amour ou
tu n'y arrives pas
[Applaudissements]
la peau couleur du soleil
elle a le secret des abeilles elle sait
comment on fait les enfants
elle c'est un avion blanc dans le ciel
elle a dit chat brûlé ses ailes elle est
née dans un ouragan
Thomas ce soir tu as envie de gagner ou
tu t'amuses simplement c'est très très
difficile
de gagner
c'est pas une petite finale c'est quand
même assez important donc
bien chanter ma chanson c'est je serai
satisfait quelque soit la place bien
chanter c'est ce qu'il me faut ce que je
voudrais tu as un vrai passionné de
karaoké qu'est-ce que tu aimes dans le
karaoké première raison c'est que
j'arrive à faire enfin je fais passer
mes sentiments par des chansons et je
veux dire ma copine dès que je dès que
j'ai une chanson d'amour je lui j'ai
envie de lui chanter et puis
je suis ou alors quand j'étais à Nevers
et qu'elle était à Dijon je lui ai
envoyé la cassette ou bien pareil pour
mon meilleur ami c'est
dès que j'arrive à
quand je peux pas exprimer mes
sentiments et que je trouvais une
chanson c'est c'est le moyen de
communication entre moi même ma copine
et mon meilleur ami cette petite copine
ça c'est une façon de lui parler d'amour
mais autrement tu lui parles d'amour ou
tu n'y arrives pas
c'est plus facile puis c'est plus
touchant je pense
parce que elle m'avait dit une fois à la
dernière présélection
elle m'avait vu chanter une chanson
d'amour et ça avait
fait quelque chose quoi des fois elle
pleure toi aussi ça te fait plaisir non
pas qu'elle pleure mais qu'elle est
autant d'émotion puis ça me fait des
frissons dans le dos quand j'arrive à
faire à chanter une chanson pour
quelqu'un c'est
dire c'est souvent que je fais ça
j'adore ça tu es venu entourer de ta
famille justement de tes deux
grands-mères vous êtes à la retraite
toutes les deux ça fait 83 ans
et de ta maman donc votre bout vous êtes
mère au foyer votre mari travaille comme
directeur commercial chez Renault vous
êtes toutes les trois des supporters
et des supportrices plus exactement
c'est la première fois
mais moi je suis
je l'encourage parce que je suis
contente de l'entendre chanter à 83 ans
j'en suis fière et moi je l'avoue
maintenant j'aimerais bien qu'ils se
lancent dans cette voie là parce que il
est doué puis il a le tempérament il a
le
punchilla vous aimeriez quoi moi
j'aimerais bien le voir célèbre quelle
est la grand-mère qui ne désirait pas ça
pour vous la réussite ça passe par le
l'affiche pas forcément mais comme lui
il adore ça déjà il a ça dans le coeur
alors moi je trouve que il faut qu'ils
suivent son idée jusqu'à bien sûr les
parents sont là c'est eux qui quand même
qui travaillent pour qui réussissent
dans la vie alors les grands-mères on
peut pas tellement disons
à faire vraiment on n'a pas de
commandement leur donner aux parents
aujourd'hui ma belle-fille n'est pas
pareil mais ma foi et mon fils non plus
hein
je veux que ça reste un loisir pas
qu'ils prennent la grosse tête et puis
qui se fasse plaisir comme il le fait
jusqu'à maintenant
faut pas que ça aille plus loin quoi je
préfère qu'il continue ses études
d'abord
qui chantent plaisir tout le temps mais
pourquoi quel est le risque
je trouve que c'est un peu éphémère et
puis et puis c'est peut-être égoïste de
ma part mais j'ai peur qu'il s'éloigne
de moi
par le karaoké ou parce que ça parle le
karaoké mais s'il en faisait son métier
parce que toi tu veux en faire ton
métier je serais pas tomber les études
pour la chanson
c'est un rêve oui il y a longtemps et
vous vous chantez facilement on va
maintenant je chante plus clair bah je
chantais bien
vous sentiez bien ah oui je chantais
bien c'est vous qui lui avait un peu
enseigné la chanson non je crois pas
non il s'est lancé avec ses copines
comme ça non c'est pas participé à
d'autres concours de karaoké
donc j'ai gagné des voyages suite de ces
finales de voyage à Ibiza pour deux
personnes et puis de voyager en Tunisie
et en Grèce donc tu as fait plein de
voyages non je les ai pas fait et
pourquoi tu nous as passé
et l'accompagne aérienne est assez cher
ah c'est juste le séjour alors c'est
frustrant un peu ouais alors je vais les
vendre je t'attends garder un
c'est important qu'il remporte la finale
oui je suis venu dans l'espoir qui gagne
et puis pour le féliciter
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]